hey gq i'm eric andre and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
god i hate the internet wikipedia
andre was born in boca raton florida on
april 4 1983
the son of an american ashkenazi jewish
mother from the upper west side of new
york city's manhattan borough
and it is incredibly specific and an
afro-haitian immigrant father
who worked as a psychiatrist it's pretty
accurate i've never heard the term
afrohaitian
my mom was born in the 40s before
suburbs were invented so there were like
working-class families in
manhattan yeah i think her rent growing
up was like three bucks
and like a shoelace andre is an atheist
and a practitioner of transcendental
meditation
yeah it's accurate enough i think
atheists agnostic
i don't believe in god but who the [ __ ]
am i what do i know
it's kind of my philosophy submit
what is it like to work behind the
scenes on the eric andre show it's
incredibly
stressful because we're pissing people
off for a living
i've gotten arrested and i've gotten
seriously injured
taking a few trips to the hospital and a
few trips to jail next
what would be the best person to go on
eric andre's show we tried to get
maya angelou on before she passed away
like a few times
we tried to get gucci mane on i don't
think gucci man has an email
does the airgundry show actually have a
live audience no
and we intentionally like use the same
sound effects over and over again so
it's like crystal clear that it's a fake
audience
we want the guests to like
psychologically unravel we don't want an
audience breaking the attention of that
next twitter
seriously it's actually me how old were
you when your dad first
thought that you were crazy lol i'm sure
like two years old my mom would go you
were in your terrible twos until you
were 13 years old then you were a
teenager
my dad ignored me until i was 20 though
so he dodged a bullet
replied what was your favorite
on the street segment i like the stuff
on the subway i do a run of things on
the subway i feel like the most
inspired on the new york city subway
it's like my happy place
eric andre so you want potus to do
criminalize all drugs are you
serious dude so you want [ __ ] like
heroin meth crack cocaine lsd flock
gotta be legal you make no sense at all
sounds like you want to destroy more
lives at a faster rate
shake my goddamn head yes i'm glad he
said this uh yes i do
here's why the war on drugs has done
nothing to curb drug addiction
we have spent billions if not trillions
of dollars on the dea and the war on
drugs which is
wasted money portugal decriminalized all
drugs and they saw a decrease
in drug addiction and a decrease in
crime
instead of treating drug addicts with
condemnation and throwing them in jail
you should treat them with compassion
and get them the help that they need
blobby light 83
you're brainwashed god i [ __ ] hate
the internet
[Laughter]
next ericante how many times did you
have to reshoot scenes for metro because
people recognize you or your co-stars
that would happen but it never really
like tanked any scene
too bad you'd have some kids come up and
get excited and like a pa or sometimes
my stunt coordinator would step in and
just be like
hey you know what we're doing also
anybody over the age of 35 has no idea
who i am
basically like you can see throughout
the movie we're just like pranking moms
god i hate that [ __ ] narc guy i'm
looking them up right now
blobby light 83 he follows me oh he's a
fan all right i like him again
um is eric andre's only fans
real what can he give us that other
people can't
i swear if it's just him playing just
the double bass yes my only fans is real
you don't have to search very hard to
find images or a video of me naked
posted eric andre i love your stuff and
everything but
how did disney hire you for the lion
king with all your nude pics on
instagram
i have no idea you know what john
favreau directed it and his
teenage son is a fan of the eric andre
show so
i have him to thank i think disney just
has no idea who i am
so i just snuck in under the radar
why is eric andre allowed to have this
show i asked myself that every day
i was on unemployment i had like 200
bucks in my bank account when i sold the
show
it's still surreal to me adult swim has
been so good to me
i don't know why they keep ordering more
seasons
posted eric andre hey how is craft punk
taking the split up of daft punk his fan
base needs to know actually i think crap
punk is
psyched because now he's it's his time
in the limelight
instagram
[Music]
how do you convince such a celebrities
to come on your show like robin gibbon's
little yachty
uh we try to show them as little of the
show as possible and tell their
publicist as little as possible
reddit
what would the u.s be like if eric andre
was our president we would tank into the
abyss i think it's the most miserable
job
in the world the economy would collapse
i'd be like asleep under my desk like
george costanza
next have eric or hannibal ever been
arrested for impersonating a police
officer
no so everything we come up with on the
show we pass through legal
we're allowed to impersonate an officer
while we're shooting a prank
in new york as long as we don't make
somebody feel like they're in danger and
we can't arrest anybody
so now i've gotten arrested for much
stupider [ __ ] submit
quota how did eric andre get his start
in comedy
it took me like a quick 10 15 years to
get started i went to a music college
for jazz daddy-o in the middle of my
college years
i started doing like open my comedy
nights and then i moved to new york
and then i continued doing chicken [ __ ]
open my comedy nights for like a decade
and then i put together a primitive
version of the argandra show
and then sold it to adult swim posted
why is eric andre obsessed with ranch
dressing uh it's delicious
salad is disgusting and vegetables are
boring and you gotta
ranch them up so i mean that question
really answers itself
how many desks has eric broken i think
we tally it up to like 14
a season and there's been five seasons
so
i'm no math expert i'm gonna say that's
like 3465 desks
and i will continue to break dust till
the day i die
[Music]
youtube
wait those reactions look too genuine is
this a movie shot with real people like
sort of compilation prank packaged
into a road trip yeah it's a narrative
it's not
a compilation like there's a narrative
thread throughout all the pranks but it
is real
prank shot with real people yes replied
instagram jared from subway
loves a lot of weight and sandwiches
this has been incredible i now want to
ride the train just to hear these
any specific station or line you did
announcements for i just did general
safety announcements
i don't know which line i'm sorry and
nobody told me they heard me
ask a new yorker i'm stuck in l.a right
now i'll be there soon
next how the she put up with you you
know what i don't know and i ask myself
that every day
consistently do and she is fine all
right guys thanks so much signing off